[Music]
imagine you have a weighted coin so the
probability of flipping heads it might
not be 50/50 exactly it could be twenty
percent or maybe 90 percent or zero
percent or thirty one point four one
five nine two percent the point is that
you just don't know but imagine that you
flip this coin ten different times and
seven of those times it comes up heads
do you think that the underlying weight
of this coin is such that each flip has
a 70% chance of coming up heads if I
were to ask you hey what's the
probability that the true probability of
flipping heads is 0.7 what would you say
this is a pretty weird question and for
two reasons first of all it's asking
about a probability of a probability as
in the value we don't know is itself
some kind of long-run frequency for a
random event which frankly is hard to
think about but the more pressing
weirdness comes from asking about
probabilities in the setting of
continuous values let's give this
unknown probability of flipping heads
some kind of name like H keep in mind
that H could be any real number from 0
up to 1 ranging from a coin that always
flips tails up to one that always flips
heads and everything in between so if I
ask hey what's the probability that H is
precisely 0.7 as opposed to say zero
point seven zero zero zero zero zero
zero one or any other nearby value well
there's going to be a strong possibility
for paradox if we're not careful it
feels like no matter how small the
answer to this question it just wouldn't
be small enough if every specific value
within some range all uncountably
infinite ly many of them has a nonzero
probability well even if that
probability was minuscule adding them
all up to get the total probability of
any one of these values will blow up to
infinity on the other hand though if all
of these probabilities are zero aside
from the fact that that now gives you no
useful information about the coin the
total sum of those probabilities would
be zero when it should be one after all
this weight of the coin H is something
so the probability of it being any one
of these values
add up to one so if these values can't
all be nonzero and they can't all be
zero what do you do where we're going
with this by the way is that I'd like to
talk about the very practical question
of using data to create meaningful
answers to these sorts of probabilities
of probabilities questions but for this
video let's take a moment to appreciate
how to work with probabilities over
continuous values and resolve this
apparent paradox the key is not to focus
on individual values but ranges of
values for example we might make these
buckets to represent the probability
that H is between say zero point eight
and zero point eight five also and this
is more important than it might seem
rather than thinking of the height of
each of these bars as representing the
probability think of the area of each
one as representing that probability
where exactly those areas come from is
something that we'll answer later for
right now just know that in principle
there's some answer to the probability
of H sitting inside one of these ranges
our task right now is to take the
answers to these very coarse-grained
questions and to get a more exact
understanding of the distribution at the
level of each individual input the
natural thing to do would be consider
finer and finer buckets and when you do
the smaller probability of falling into
any one of them is accounted for in the
thinner width of each of these bars
while the heights are going to stay
roughly the same that's important
because it means that as you take this
process to the limit you approach some
kind of smooth curve so even though all
of the individual probabilities of
falling into any one particular bucket
will approach zero the overall shape of
the distribution is preserved and even
refined in this limit if on the other
hand we had let the heights of the bars
represent probabilities everything would
have gone to zero
so in the limit we would have just had a
flatline giving no information about the
overall shape of the distribution so
wonderful letting area represent
probability help solve this problem but
let me ask you if the y-axis no longer
represents probability what exactly are
the units here since probability sits in
the area of these bars or width times
height the height represents a kind of
probability per unit in the x-direction
what's known in the business as a
probability density the other thing to
keep in mind is that the total area of
all these bars has to equal one at every
level of the process that's something
that has to be true for any valid
probability distribution the idea of
probability density is actually really
clever when you step back to think about
it as you take things to the limit even
if there's all sorts of paradoxes
associated with assigning a probability
to each of these uncountably infinite ly
many values of H between zero and one
there's no problem if we associate a
probability density to each one of them
giving what's known as a probability
density function or PDF for short
anytime you see a PDF in the wild the
way to interpret it is that the
probability of your random variable
lying between two values equals the area
under this curve between those values so
for example what's the probability of
getting any one very specific number
like zero point seven well the area of
an infinitely thin slice is zero so it's
zero what's the probability of all of
them put together well the area under
the full curve is one you see paradox
sidestepped and the way that it's been
sidestepped is a bit subtle in normal
finite settings like rolling a die or
drawing a card the probability that a
random value falls into a given
collection of possibilities is simply
the sum of the probabilities of being
any one of them this feels very
intuitive it's even true in a countably
infinite context but to deal with the
continuum the rules themselves have
shifted the probability of falling into
a range of values is no longer the sum
of the probabilities of each individual
value
instead probabilities associated with
ranges are the fundamental primitive
objects and the only sense in which it's
meaningful to talk about an individual
value here is to think of it as a range
of width:0 if the idea of the rules
changing between a finite setting and a
continuous one feels unsettling well
you'll be happy to know that
mathematicians are way ahead of you
there's a field of math called measure
theory which helps to unite these two
settings and make rigorous the idea of
associating numbers like probabilities
to various subsets of all possibilities
in a way that combines and distributes
nicely for example let's say you're in a
setting where you have a random number
the equals 0 with 50% probability and
the rest of the time it's some positive
number according to a distribution that
looks like half of a bell curve this is
an awkward middle ground between a
finite context where a single value has
a nonzero probability and a continuous
one where probabilities are found
according to areas under the appropriate
density function this is the sort of
thing that measure Theory handles very
smoothly
I mentioned this mainly for the
especially curious viewer and you can
find more reading material in the
description it's a pretty common rule of
thumb that if you find yourself using a
sum in a discrete context then use an
integral in the continuous context which
is the tool from calculus that we use to
find areas under curves in fact you
could argue this video would be way
shorter if I just said that at the front
and called it good for my part though I
always found it a little unsatisfying to
do this blindly without thinking through
what it really means and in fact if you
really dig into the theoretical
underpinnings of integrals what you'd
find is that in addition to the way that
it's defined in a typical intro calculus
class there is a separate more powerful
definition that's based on measure
theory this formal foundation of
probability
if I look back to when I first learned
probability I definitely remember
grappling with this weird idea that in
continuous settings like random
variables that are real numbers or
throwing a dart at a dartboard
you have a bunch of outcomes that are
possible and yet each one has a
probability of 0 and somehow all
together they have a probability of 1
now one step of coming to terms with
this is to realize that possibility is
better tied to probability density than
probability but just swapping out sums
of one for integrals of the others never
quite scratch to the itch for me I
remember that it only really clicked
when I realized that the rules for
combining probabilities of different
sets were not quite what I thought they
were and there was simply a different
axiom system underlying it all but
anyway steering away from the theory
somewhere back in the loose direction of
application look back to our original
question about the coin with an unknown
weight what we've learned here is that
the right question to ask is what's the
probability density function that
describes this value H after seeing the
outcomes of a few tosses if you can find
that PDF you can use it to answer
questions like what's the probability
that the true probability of flipping
heads falls between point six and point
eight to find that PDF join me in the
next part
[Music]
[Music]
you
[Music]